a board charged with identifying and
making available all records related to
the assassination of President Kennedy
presented its final report today during
a ceremony at the National Archives
members of the assassination records
review board presented the report to the
deputy archivist the events about 50
minutes good morning everyone my name is
John Thune I'm I've had the honor of
serving as the chair of the
assassination records Review Board for
the past four years and were pleased
this morning to be able to present the
final report of the assassination
records Review Board the report
summarizes the extraordinary experience
that we've had over the past four and a
half years in locating obtaining
reviewing and most importantly releasing
the record of the tragic assassination
of President John F Kennedy in 1963 the
review board has been armed with the
power of Independence and the power of
due process and blessed I believe with
the enduring values of history and the
law and we have brought to this process
this effort an orderly and thoughtful
procedure for reviewing these important
records the statute that was originally
passed in 1992 was designed to open vast
quantities of material to attempt to
convey the full story of the
assassination and yet still protect
those pieces of information that still
required protection and in that task
I believe the review board has succeeded
in its effort the shroud of secrecy that
has sheltered these records for three
decades I think has caused great harm
and when the board examined these
documents with balanced judgment it was
obvious that very little still required
protection today 35 years after this
terrible event and harm has been caused
to the nation who has been confused
about who did what and who did this
terrible deed and the harm has been
caused I believe two government agencies
themselves who in the name of protecting
their interests succeeded in undermining
their legitimacy as democratic
institutions and I think also there has
been harm to the fragile and very
important ideal that the American public
trusts its government to tell the truth
the records that are at the National
Archives at College Park show a Warren
Commission that was not dealing with a
full deck and a House Select Committee
on assassinations that was dealing with
too many decks and not enough time to
play a hand it is a treasure trove of
documents films and artifacts that the
Review Board believes provides an
extraordinary and rare open window on a
critical part of our nation's history
the early 1960s and as well the Board
believes that the collection includes a
fairly complete record of the nation's
reaction to the surprising assassination
of its leader during the height of the
Cold War and the many suspicions at that
engendered the review board's legacy is
the four million plus pages of materials
at the National Archives which await the
interpretive skills of researchers and
historians the board's ultimate legacy I
believe has hopefully been to
demonstrate that throughout the course
of history it is better to be open than
to be secretive it is
better to spend money sharing
information than hiding it and better to
establish a process that focuses on an
orderly opening rather than a process
that grants unfettered discretion to the
censors I want to take a moment today to
express the thanks of the Review Board
to our our agency partners that we have
worked with throughout this long effort
they have truly become our partners in
many respects we have had many spirited
battles many disagreements about what
can be opened today but in the end I
believe that our work and the work of
the agencies has been in the public
interest and will result in a great
amount of material being open to the
public so I want to thank our agency
partners for all of their long work and
help and I want to thank the staff of
the assassination records Review Board
over these past four years they have
been a remarkable staff they have been
asked to do an enormous job in a
relatively short period of time the job
of searching in every corner and every
file cabinet for records that may
possibly be relevant to the
assassination and I want to express my
thanks and the thanks to the board to
each and every one of them especially
our staff that remained with us to the
end and in my view they're truly the
a-team the people that worked long long
hours in the past two months to finish
up all of the work of the board and to
work on this very important final report
that we present today and it's
especially important I think and
significant that we return today to this
room the archivists reception room in
the National Archives from which we
began our work over four years ago with
our first meeting as a review board and
to that extent it provides some closure
to this effort and a chance to recognize
the National Archives and Records
Administration which
has truly done a great job throughout
this entire process they have been I
think the review board's ultimate
partner in this effort I want to
especially thank Steve Tilly who has
been with us from the beginning the
person who is in charge of the
collection at College Park he has been
exceptional and we're counting on his
good work to continue the effort to make
these materials available to the public
and to collect further records that we
expect will be coming in in the months
and hopefully years to come so thank you
Steve for your fine work
finally I want to thank the public that
has helped us throughout this effort and
that is very important we have tried
from day one as a review board to
communicate as much as we possibly could
with the American public to take their
ideas their theories their suggestions
and put them to work to try to find
records that people believe might have
existed so we thank the public for that
communication the ongoing communication
that we've had through the public
meetings through the hearings that we
have had and through the letters and
calls that we've received literally
daily throughout this entire effort
thank you that has been an important
part of this effort and public
participation in this event that is long
overdue I'd like to ask dr. Lewis
Bilardo who is the deputy archivist of
the United States to come forward right
now I'd like to present dr. Blair doe
with a copy of the final report of the
assassination records Review Board in
the hope that the National Archives will
continue its important stewardship of
these records and to make them freely
available to the public not only today
and tomorrow but for generations to come
thank you dr. Blair
thank you judge tunheim and members and
staff of the review board I do want to
say that as you had indicated this was
an enormous job that this board and
staff undertook we received this report
with with great gratitude do want to say
that a remarkable body of records have
come to the National Archives because of
this work both government records as
well as some private materials as well
and not only are is an enormous amount
of documentation now exists about the
events if November 1963 in Dallas but
interestingly enough a large body of
material shedding light on other aspects
of government policy that we would never
have thought of when this whole thing
began for example American policy
relationship to Cuba the American policy
early in the early 1960s as it relates
to Vietnam and last but not least also
the investigations of the Justice
Department and the FBI as it relates to
organized crime so again thank you very
much for this and for the records that
have come our way take care
I'd like to ask other review board
members to speak now and present some of
their thoughts about this great event
I'm Henry Graff professor emeritus at
Columbia University in the history
department I would like to make a very
few and very brief comments underscoring
some of the points that Judge tunheim
offered we have to see that this board
had as its prime goal
the restoration insofar as we could
participate in the process of faith of
the people in the government of the
United States and we'd like to believe
that this above all the documents is our
major contribution and I'd like to add
also that just as the assassination is a
significant event in the history of the
Cold War the various theories the doubts
among the American people about what
actually happened on that awful day in
Dallas all of that is part also of
history a history that includes the
Vietnam War and includes Watergate goes
back perhaps to the Bay of Pigs
more recently it involves the medical
consequences of certain drugs and
perhaps whatever else even including
Agent Orange material that affected
gravely the lives of soldiers all of
this contributed to a terrible sense in
the public that the government was
hiding things and what our board was
created to produce is as President Bush
said in the message that he issued at
the time of the signing of the
legislation creating the JFK a
collection Act the aim primarily was to
restore the confidence
in the American people that the
government doesn't lie we don't know
that we have answered all the questions
that will arise that have arisen but
we'd like to think we've made a major
contribution in that regard a smattering
of applause Henry I'm Herman Hall Dean
of the College of Humanities at Ohio
State University the Ohio State
University and I'm also a professor of
history in the law I first want to thank
Jack tunheim for his leadership on the
board this was a really complex group of
people I think to work with jack has
shown great skill and keeping us
together and moving us toward our
objective Benjamin Franklin once said
that for three to keep a secret two must
be dead and if there is any testimony to
make about the work of the board that
even with all three dead it's possible
for the government to still want to keep
things under wraps if there is anything
that stands out about our work it is
that the Shroud of the Cold War still
rests over us that we can have documents
that are more in some cases more than 40
years old that the various government
agencies sought to protect is I think a
sad commentary on where we are with
openness nonetheless the board with
extraordinary powers an extraordinary
mandate tremendous sympathy I think on
the part of the community researchers
who have been out there working on the
assassination as I think put a profound
punctuation mark on the cause of
openness I went to however remind all of
you who are in this room all of you who
work in the archives all of you who
represent the agencies that the work of
the assassination records Review Board
while the board itself has finished is
far from done for it is important to
remember that there are documents yet to
be released their documents that are
redacted that will open between now the
year 2017
and without your conscious involvement
and continuing oversight and continuing
awareness that these documents deserve
to be open there are I think within the
government forces that will push just
the opposite direction so the challenge
I think for all of us is to remember
that the boards work the five of us are
finished but the spirit and the legacy
of the act go on and it's up to all of
you to make sure that government does
the right thing and that is to ensure
that that the lessons of secrecy are in
fact learned it's I think important to
remember as well that the legacy of this
board is hardly written today there are
approaching five million documents out
there and there will be more that will
be added to the collection over the year
it will be a decade I would submit to
you before we know what the real impact
of these documents are until scholars
and researchers have the opportunity to
work their way through them and in
working their way through them come to
understand they're really tremendous
significance of of what I believe we've
we've done earth so whatever story you
write whatever message you send it needs
to be a message that the story remains
to be completed both of the oversight of
the process of making sure that that
which we declare to be open is open that
for scholars and researchers to come to
rights of story I think in conclusion
that we all recognize that Justice
Robert Jackson was absolutely right when
he said that the Constitution is not a
suicide pact and by that Jackson meant
there are some secrets that are clearly
worth retaining and keeping because
they're in the public interest but after
four years and more than four million
documents surely we can all agree that
the numbers of those secrets are fewer
than one would have believed and more
profoundly one of the greatest threats
to our Liberty is the continuing
insistence that we we have more rather
than fewer secrets thank you
I'm Anna Nelson and I teach in the
history department at American
University as a person who has done
research and has taught American foreign
policy in the post-war period I was
always standing on the other side of the
barricades of secrecy always filing in
Freedom of Information requests and
harassing the National Archives for
documents and I think that it gave me a
very interesting perspective on what was
behind those barricades it wasn't always
something that I thought it was or
anyone else thought it was it has been
pointed out we soon came to discover
that many other records had been
released 20 years ago I think that there
were several unique things about what we
did one of the things is simply that
five of us came together from five
different communities you might say even
though we may share professional
interests we were all engaged in other
activities and without fail we agreed on
what to open five American citizens can
simply determine that after 35 years
there are some things too close to
protect people and there are most things
too open and we had a lot of learning to
do as a group but it was a very
interesting experience if we differed it
was often because one of us wanted to
open more it was almost never because we
decided to open less the second thing I
think that's important is that we have
through our work reached to audiences
one of course the one we were set out to
help were those people who have worked
on the
assassination done research on it
studied it for so many years and had
lost his confidence in what they were
finding as the documents eat doubt one
by one half blacked out on a page but
the other group that we have also helped
our researchers in every field and in
the long run American citizens because
we have opened so many documents from
the early 60s and we have learned the
public will learn a great deal about as
was mentioned before a great deal about
what in fact was the situation of the
government the government agencies and
very formative years in the early 1960s
begin to unfold because we had the
statute we had there are some documents
that came out automatically simply
because of the various agencies and the
presidential libraries knew that we were
in fact in business so I think we have
done our work well I think that I all of
us would agree with each other I think
at this point with some of the salient
features but I think that to me the
uniqueness and the product those
marvelous documents in the National
Archives will in fact remain our legacy
my name is Bill Joyce and my day job so
to speak is at the Princeton University
Library I'd like to say a few things
this morning and I think I'd like to
start by thanking or chairman our
colleague Jack tunheim for his very
skillful leadership first and bringing
the five of us together then assembling
a staff and finally working with the
public with the various government
agencies to move the help of excuse me
move the work of the board forward so
that we might begin to accomplish some
of what we set out to do second I think
I'd like to pay tribute to the staff a
more dedicated and loyal group of people
I can't imagine
we are very blessed to have had their
good work over the years and to have
been so sensual in in some respects and
guiding us as board members in terms of
what we've been able to accomplish they
deserve our heartiest thanks and
appreciation for the good effort that
they have put into this project Anna
said that the legacy of the board is in
the collection that a compilation of
four plus million pages of material at
College Park in the archives building
out there that is certainly the case and
as my colleague Kermit Hall has pointed
out the material that is there awaits
the attention of the historians the
journalists the researches to probe into
that material it is an extraordinarily
deep slice of information into the
workings of the government at a
tumultuous time in the history of the
Republic and I believe that our legacy
in terms of our contribution to
historical knowledge can scarcely be
plumb now but over the course of time
will become apparent to all of us but I
believe there is a second and equally
important legacy that we have created
and that is the process the model that
we have been a
to put into place using the legislation
the powers that were conferred upon us
to create a process by which we could
declassify federal records it is
important for all of us to recognize the
steps that we were able to take to work
to open increasing numbers of documents
some of them very sensitive indeed and
they believe that the procedures that we
were able to adopt have an impact and
have an importance that we must all pay
attention to
Kermit hall called attention to the fact
that it is responsibility of all of us
now that the board goes out of business
to remember that the work of opening
these records continues and I think in
that spirit we must all remember that it
is our responsibility to keep after this
to try to counter forces that do not
want these records to be opened and to
continue to work to accomplish as much
as we possibly can the openness not only
concerning the assassination but all
aspects of public life that is after all
our responsibilities as citizens thank
you
thank you very much to my fellow board
members and let me just add in closing
my thanks to all of them for being a
truly superb group of individuals very
talented and intelligent in their own
right and I think the collective
experience of this board has been an
outstanding piece of work and I want to
salute them for for that that effort
there's a couple of people that I want
to point out that I've seen here this
morning that just among a group of many
people who should be mentioned I already
mentioned Steve Tilly and he's important
but the person who served as our last
executive director of the review board
over the past several months which has
been a difficult time wrapping
everything up Laura dank Laura would you
wave wherever you are right in the back
and a bit earlier I saw and I'm not sure
if he's still here our first executive
director who really set up this entire
process dr. David Marr well there he has
David wave for a moment they were two of
the leaders of a very very fine staff a
group of as they've been called loyal
and dedicated employees and they
certainly have been and we've enjoyed
every minute of working with them now
the board will take a few questions if
you have questions to ask why don't I
get everyone up here so that we can all
participate in this way we need to stand
up here so
Bob go ahead before your arrival here
this morning one of the conspiracy
authors held forth it late at the links
telling us that's your investigation of
the autopsy findings of the medical
findings
proved what he and other conspiracy
theorists have said all along that there
was a conspiracy to distort the autopsy
and hide that what had been a a
collective conspiracy is that the view
of any or all of you or is that a trap
you fell into why recreating the autopsy
and casting doubt on its findings let me
answer that Bob by saying that we
attempted with the autopsy report to try
to clarify some of the many questions
that have been raised throughout the
years to the extent that clarifying
could be done now thirty five years
after the event we did our best to do
that I think we have shed greater light
on the autopsy findings which of course
have been among the most secretive
findings throughout the years and so I
think that we didn't attempt to reach
any particular conclusion about it we
tried to answer questions about what
additional records might be available
again to prepare those records for the
American public to make up their own
minds about it breathe at the end
results of your finding is not to
reassure the public and to mute their
suspicions about the assassination but
to add fresh doubts that will increase
the suspicions and I know you didn't
intend this but would you agree that is
the result you're speaking of our entire
effort now it's time
that but let me just say that we took
this investigation of the records which
is what this has been not an
investigation of the assassination
itself but a hunt and search for the
records to every possible place we could
take it
we didn't prejudge any of the results
and we don't really prejudge the answers
either the answers are really to be left
to the researchers to the writers who
will have the time and effort ability to
go through these records over a length
of time and reach their own conclusions
about what happened I'm convinced that
there will be many conclusions reached
from that because that's the nature of
this particular episode of American
history we're too far beyond the event
right now to have the kind of conclusive
answers that the American public would
like to see and so the answers will lie
in the work of the researchers and
interpreters in the years to come well
with the State Department we had no
problems with them and their release of
their own records in fact that process
moved very smoothly and they were very
dedicated to the law a portion of the
law instructed the Department of State
to assist us in trying to obtain release
of KGB records in Moscow and in Minsk
the records that through our
investigation we know exists in fact
we've seen many of them we've not been
able to obtain all what we would have
liked to have obtained and in part where
our criticism of the State Department is
that they really didn't spend enough
time helping us with that effort as far
as the president's foreign intelligence
board we worked with them late in the
process and and felt that they believed
that they had an exemption from this act
which is not apparent from the face of
the Act I think in the end their records
will be released like everyone else but
it was
little difficult task working with them
at the end check could I do something
here too I think that that both of these
matters are really of some moment we
know that materials are in the former
Soviet Union Jack and I Jack and I and
David Marr well certainly had the
opportunity to see them and Vince it's
just very unfortunate recognizing that
the relationship with the government of
Belarus is not the best still very
unfortunate that we couldn't bring more
effective diplomatic initiative to
support our effort to work there and
much the same I think with with with
Russia where we have every reason to
believe that there are additional
records relating to especially Oswald
and in terms of the president's foreign
intelligence advisory board we all need
to keep in mind that there's a learning
process and unfortunately they didn't
get their schooling early enough and the
result of this is that I think they hold
to some views about their authority
relative to the authority of the Act
that are not I think very progressive
and certainly are not going to be very
hopeful if they aren't forthcoming with
their records in really amplifying the
context in which the assassination took
took place so I need your questions
right on target and it's just
regrettable that we didn't get a little
bit more activity out of these two well
their view of their authority to be
independent of the scope of our of our
act and you know they they take I think
the position although you'd have to talk
with them they take the position that
they're they're essentially a private
advisory group to the to the to the
president and that they can't render a
good judgment unless they know that
everything they say is to be maintained
and absolute secrecy well I would submit
to you that is no way to run a democracy
and it's certainly no way to preserve
Liberty in the face of secrecy and
there's every reason to believe that
they're covered as comprehensively as we
are as all the other agencies are by by
the end
part of this to answer your question as
a matter of timing we had we did have
delay we actually had a sunset provision
of three years we had it extended for
four years largely because we could not
complete the CIA records we did not want
to go out of business unless we had
completed those records so delay is a
wonderful way to avoid coming to grips
with what was this necessary and the
same was true with the foreign records
there was a window of opportunity with
Belarus which we lost because of the
State Department losing a cable or not
finding the table and so that was this
kind of delay that I mean the remarkable
thing is we really thought we'd be
through processing records in early
August records were processed over this
last weekend we still have two
outstanding issues before we go out of
business tomorrow so timing has been
very critical to what we've done all the
way along the road yes I would like to
respond a little further to Bob Clark
who has been an old supporter I think of
our process and with whom we've had many
contacts the board does not subscribe to
any conspiracy theory it was not
intending to create a new conspiracy
theory in getting at the autopsy
photographs our mission has not been to
redo the Warren Commission report our
mission was to open documents and I know
the law of unintended consequences I
think that was what Bob had in mind when
he wondered what will happen to the
product to the legacy of this board we
don't know our intentions were however
not to create new conspiracy theories
because that was not what we were organ
nice appointed by the president
confirmed by the Congress to do part of
our work was to seek out records
wherever they existed whether they were
in local government hands state
government hands or private hands as
well we encouraged donations of records
and films and other artifacts to this
collection and we were really blessed by
an enormous amount of donated material
which now is available to the American
public one of the most important aspects
of this I think are the records from the
New Orleans chapter of this event the
prosecution in 1967 of Clay Shaw by
District Attorney Jim Garrison virtually
all the records that remain from that
event have been donated to the
collection including the long secret
grand jury testimony from that
proceeding we faced a few obstacles in
New Orleans but by and large we got
great cooperation there we got good
cooperation in Dallas as well especially
with the donation of additional films
which will enrich this collection could
you just take off some of the new
material that you are some of the things
we haven't seen before well we're not
technically releasing new material today
because we've been working on this
effort for four years and we have been
releasing material as it has become
available but I think generally if you
look at the collection some of the most
important documents include the
documents about Cuba and Operation
Mongoose which was in operation in the
early 1960s to try to destabilize and
perhaps even assassinate Castro those
records are very
significant they were caught up in the
sweep of these records because of our
broad definition of an assassination
record also I think of significant
interest are all of the records of the
mysterious visit that Lee Harvey Oswald
allegedly made in Mexico City in late
September early October of 1963 in which
he sought passage through Cuba to the
back to the Soviet Union the
investigative reports on that visit have
now been made public through the work of
the review board with very little
redactions and I think that's a very
significant collection as well should be
clarified because you didn't intend to
say that you're taking a no conspiracy
position your position is that you're
not taking a position on whether there
was a conspiracy or there wasn't but
your staff did conduct one of the most
important inquiries in this country's
history in that it re-interviewed the
autopsy doctors over the last two years
and the photographic personnel in the
weight of that evidence tends to
indicate that the evidence in the
National Archives is false but you don't
have to comment on that that's not part
of your report we accept the invitation
it's certainly not the case so we
anticipate presenting our report
tomorrow to the president there has been
no embargo on any aspect of the report
it's it's there's no part of it that's
being held up or anything we're just
we're just going to present the report
to the president tomorrow who has been
very interested in our work and remains
very interested in seeking open
the opening of all these materials we're
not sure we're not sure yet it certainly
will be open to the press yeah certainly
and this Sullivan can get you a copy of
the report yeah what kind of a lesson is
there to be learned about the Warren
Commission how how much damage did they
do
by the way they conducted their inquiry
feeding and fanning the flames of the
structure well you have to remember that
the Warren Commission did its work
during the height of the Cold War when
there was extreme reservations of public
disclosure of anything I think what our
work has done has demonstrated that the
Warren Commission worked very hard in a
very limited period of time to get at
the answers here but there was a lot of
information that was not shared with the
Warren Commission the CIA did not share
information the FBI did not share much
of its information about organized crime
again in the in the context of national
security so you have to look at what the
Warren Commission did in the context of
the times and the fact that they did not
have access to materials that they
should have had access to at the time go
ahead and that is commented upon in the
report yes actually we did but the the
thing about the Warren Commission it
seems to me is that they had a very
limited amount of time but they also
were operating in a period of if you
when you study the go back and read
about what Lyndon Johnson was concerned
about and in a period of time where
there was a kind of a frantic belief
that there was a very dangerous time
that that perhaps this had been done by
the Russians or that it was a very
dangerous so they they were very eager
to proceed quickly and they were very
eager not to stir up and stimulate any
more trouble than they could cope with
and so that's part of the problem but
the real problem was that the Warren
Commission hid their documents too as
did the House Select Committee
I hide their documents and the church
committee we thought had all the
documents out there they also put
documents away so that each time the
assassination was investigated the
investigating bodies tended to hide the
documents so nobody could see who had
said what and what had been done and
that I think has stimulated a great deal
of problems the the work of the Warren
Commission is a striking example of the
way in which the event of the
assassination was so enmeshed in a
matrix of the Cold War I think is very
important to understand that the
assassination and the investigative
efforts that followed it were so so much
involved in so many events that we have
now come to characterize as the Cold War
the fact that we were able to take
advantage of the end of the Cold War by
grace of the legislation and good timing
I think has contributed to our ability
to to get at more of this information
but you must see the event for what it
was and that was in the events the
context of the Cold War